[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes I don't think you could ask for a
better spot to watch what will be an
incredible display release that's what
we've been promised but I spoke to
London mare city cars a little bit
earlier he said forget New York forget
Moscow forget Athens I'm sorry James
Matthews forget edinburgh this is where
you want to be to see 2019 come in
london i the focus of this fantastic
fireworks displays eight tons of
fireworks are going to be set up in
smoke in just about 15 minutes time as
you said it is a wonderfully mild
evening not a spot of rain that of
course is a very welcome news to the
hundred thousand people who have turned
up to watch the fireworks display as i
said a hundred thousand people have got
tickets this with a sold-out event i say
this mod the best book just behind us
here it's going to use let's have a chat
with some of them ello there what's your
name where you come right now from wales
you've got a whale's out why'd you come
to London this evening just for the
atmosphere really it's really it's a
really nice crowd the fireworks I'm sure
gonna be amazing we were here in 2011
and my neighbor incredible land so we're
looking forward to seeing them again and
I was speaking to you bit earlier so
you're a bit of sort of New Year's
fireworks aficionados aren't you tell us
where you've been around the world we've
been see in New York we've been to Vegas
for fiends Paris is it is it wrong to
say that London's always the best what
do you think
yeah the crowd are amazing isten
everyone's getting her ready and it must
be waiting so long so we're just really
looking forward to it yeah I mean cuz
you've been down here since about 7:00
p.m. wasn't I think we first what to do
yeah yeah six we started in the gates
the many I serve it onwards so yeah has
been really really good and how much
feeling have you got left in your feet
sorry
how much feeling have you got left in
your feet you know it's about we've been
dancing a little better so aggregates we
keep it warm it's wonderful we'll enjoy
the fireworks was Scott you've got I
think it's one of the best have a
wonderful evening
hello there how are you all you're on
Sky News what's your name
Nana genera where do you have you come
from busy mention Ella you've come all
the way from Birmingham is this your
family here yes so who have you got here
with you daddy system and this is your
first time at London for the fireworks
and you've got such an amazing view can
you believe you're going to be so close
to it not really
are you a big fireworks fan yes
wonderful but have a fantastic evening
and you've come from but you've come
from Birmingham to see you there and why
come to London every year so we have we
have watch it from TV and this is my big
night because it's my first time
you will be amazing night it was a
wonderful to come down with all your
family they've been very patient
it's been quite cold but it will it will
be a worthy to watch here this is
amazing as London is amazing London Eye
is amazing so wonderful well already I
can tell you're gonna have a wonderful
evening
thank you so much as speaking to us have
a great time
Oh happy New Year to you well in 15
minutes I'm here to say it properly see
who else we can speak to we'll do some
wonderful walking backwards hello again
we spoke a little bit earlier how are
you feeling we what's your name reminder
Jordan stick cold but wonderful I mean
it's been a fantastic atmosphere here
hasn't it let seen a wonderful music
because I've been an important part of
this evening for you oh you won't come
back next year in for advanced that you
have to buy your tickets you plan this
in September
what have a fantastic evening enjoy you
are an amazing spot directly opposite
the London Eye let's drift a little bit
further down as I said the theme of
receiving fireworks is London it's open
it's a message and then the London
netted eat corn told me was extremely
important for him he wanted the whole
world to know that London was a global
city we're expecting the soundtrack to
this evening to feature lots of European
artists that's a very pointed choice
by the lord mayor's office by the London
mayors often associate say and they want
this to be known as a fireworks display
that is good for London and one that
they say shows in the city is indeed a
global city I've already spoken to you
you have you come all the way from
Norwich so excited so you can you
believe that after all this time it's
what you've been waiting for 15 years to
come there 50 no I can't wait I can't I
can't believe it I never how wonderful
wonderful we'll have a fantastic evening
let's give you that last lift at the
lungs and I before we hand back to you
there in the studio enjoy what will be
no doubt a fantastic fireworks display
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so now it's time to tell agency the old
traditional over time as we bid farewell
to 2018 and will come in 2019
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where it's a 2019 London make some noise
I think we should have a little
after-party
[Music]